turner classic movies began a new series
recently called
reframed classics that provides
historical context for problematic but
iconic films
but what about the films that weren't
iconic what about the films that totally
bombed
they need context too so we're gonna
give it to you in a segment called
reframed flops
[Music]
welcome to reframed flops our first film
is widely acknowledged as
the single biggest box office flop in
history
that film is john carter but what
happened
where did it go wrong let's delve deeper
the story of a confederate soldier who
goes to mars wait
the hero was a confederate soldier yikes
well when did it come out 2012
what i thought it was a silent film
oh man okay well yeah i think we know
why it bumped context added let's move
on
our next film lost almost 100 million
dollars when it was released in 1999.
the film is the 13th warrior
what happened where did it go wrong the
story which follows a band of vikings
stars antonio banderas as a muslim poet
antonio banderas plays a muslim poet
are we talking about zorro they couldn't
find a muslim actor
for that role was omar sharif not
available
he was available he also appeared in the
movie
and he said the script was so bad it
made him physically ill
and pushed him to temporarily retire
from acting dang
okay this is going a lot faster than i
anticipated context added let's move on
our final film from 2011 is
the lone ranger starring army hammer as
the lone ranger bad start
and johnny depp as tonto okay context
added
that was dumb they were dumb this
segment is over
[Music]
you